[music]
Yeah. So, as as introduced, my name is
Andrew. I'm one of the co-founders at
Roto AI. Uh, in a roto, we do we're
[snorts] really redefining uh robotic
intelligence. Uh, so the way I view kind
of robotics, maybe this is
oversimplifying it, but I think there's
broadly two categories of robots out
there in the world. There are robots
that largely follow, you know,
pre-programmed trajectories or that
break apart, you know, the the problem
of perception decision-m from following,
you know, a somewhat pre-programmed
trajectory as kind of one category. And
I put this in the, you know, industrial
automation category. And there's a
second category of robotics, which is
learning enabled robots. Robots that
where the promise is that you can learn
end to end from some robot data set and
then handle tasks that have some
inherent variability. uh and these I
would call learning capable robots. Uh
the reality is that today uh I would
argue that there's virtually zero
learning capable robots deployed in the
real world. So if you go to a factory or
a warehouse, there's you know thousands
or maybe tens of thousands of robots
deployed that follow pretty much
predefined trajectories or do relatively
repeatable actions, but there's almost
no robots that actually, you know, learn
in their environments and do dynamically
difficult tasks. And this is this is
really the problem that we set out to
address when we started ROA. And so this
is this is you know kind of the way to
[snorts] look at it. Robots don't
generalize. There's traditional
automation today which is single
trajectory task specific can't deal with
variability. And there's you know
learning or or VALA based uh and these
approaches typically are very you know
narrow brittle and they fail when
they're outside of distribution. And
this results in policies that aren't
reliable enough to deploy into the real
world. This of course is a funny video
um of of of maybe that illustrates what
some of these obstacles are. Uh but I
want to dig into this you know a little
bit more technically. The the prevailing
approach in robotics over the last
couple of years has been something
called the VA. I'm sure everyone here
has heard the abbreviation. It stands
for vision language action model. And
this approach to robotics is essentially
taking a language model. So a VLM like a
language model like Chad GPT or or
Gemini and then post-training it with
robot data. Uh and this seems like a
reasonable approach because you know
language models are are smart and
impressive. So you know why not try to
build a robot policy on top of that. And
so what a lot of the you know leading
robotics labs over the last multiple
years like you know PI and Tesla have
been doing is taking these language
models collecting robot data sets
typically through teleoperation and then
using those robot data sets to post-rain
the language models and what this
results in is a model that has a good
understanding of language because it's
it's a language model. So you describe
something to it like pick up the can and
it knows what a can is because that's
that's what a language model can do. uh
but has a pretty weak action prior
because you can't actually learn physics
and action manipulation from language
models. So it's everything it's learning
about actions is actually coming from a
very limited robot teleoperation data
set. And so this is really the problem
with VAS and as a result of that there's
a lot of you know pretty cool lab demos
you can do with VAS but there's almost
none deployed running at full autonomy
uh in the real world. So we wanted to
challenge this paradigm and we looked at
well how have AI models that have
actually been deployed in the real world
been trained. Uh and interestingly you
know we have a couple really strong
examples. There's there's language
models, there's video models, there's
image generation models. These things
generalize. They're very powerful and
they're used more and more in
enterprise. Uh and the approach to
training them is really very consistent.
You start with an internet scale
pre-training. So in the case of you know
Chad GPT's language model, OpenAI
trained on literally the entire internet
of text. Uh and once you train on an
internet scale data set, you really
learn a modality very well. And so in
the case of language, this is where you
understand, you know, logic, reasoning,
um you know, semantics, grammar, and
then once you have the pre-training, you
do some fine-tuning. And fine-tuning is
where you teach a a model to operate in
the modality that's relevant to your
problem. So in the case of language
models, this is a question and answer
kind of chatbot interface. Uh the issue
in robotics is that there is no webcale
pre-training. uh you can collect a lot
of you know robot data you can collect
teleoperation data or maybe ooi data or
simulation data uh and these are all
helpful for post-raining but they have
critical problems when you try to use
them from pre for pre-training and the
the the core problem is that when you're
pre-training a model you need a data set
that has internet scale which basically
a massive you know data set created over
decades by all of humanity and then
secondly you need very high levels of
diversity there's a reason open AI
doesn't only train on Wikipedia. They
also train on Reddit and Twitter which
you know might be questionable source of
information. You need that diversity.
You need the different style of
information, different style of uh you
know writing in order to create a robust
model. And if you try to simulate your
data, you might get a lot of volume. You
could create probably an internet scale
of sim data, but it'll have pretty low
diversity because it's trained in the
same it's created in the same simulator.
If you tell operate, you could maybe get
some more diversity, but you're going to
struggle to get a lot of scale. Um so we
felt like was necessary is to solve
robotics you need an internet data set
that is has massive scale massive
diversity and can actually teach you
about physics and our core hypothesis at
ROA was that the right data set for this
is actually internet video and what
inspired this approach is uh openai
released in 2024 a video model called
Sora and this is the first you know kind
of worldclass generative video model and
what's happening here is it takes it it
takes a text prompt here it's a stylish
woman walking through uh Tokyo at night
and it generates this video. Uh and
what's interesting is that this model is
entirely trained on video. There's no
like rules of physics or laws of motion
that are encoded here. And yet the way
the city reflects in the glasses and the
handbag moves clearly shows that the
model has an intuitive understanding of
physics. And so our insight was why
don't we use internet scale video to
teach the model physics and then we post
train with robot data to connect that
modality of an understanding of physics
to robot actions. Um and so step one we
pre-train a large model on internet
scale video you know preserving that
massive internet quantity of data but
also the diversity. And step two is
fine-tune that with robot trajectory
data. And so this is really our our
model approach. And I'm gonna I'm gonna
go through this pretty quickly, but the
way we architected our AI model is it
works in two steps. Uh if the robot's
trying to do something like say grab
this remote, first it's going to
generate a video of the robot grabbing
this remote. And then once it's
generated that video, it's going to
convert that video into actions in real
time. Um, and this this seems like a
pretty simple way to use video, but it's
actually uh quite profound and different
from typical robot policies because
usually robots learn how to do tasks
from robot data, which means if you want
to learn a new task, you need to collect
a lot more robot data. Here, all of the
reasoning on how to do the task is
actually happening in the video space,
which means you're [snorts] learning how
to do a task from in in a video
modality, and you already have access to
an internet scale video data set. So
this means that we can learn tasks
without needing to collect additional
robot data sets as this model scales.
And what we found is that if you can
have a very accurate video of a robot
doing a task, it starts to become a
onetoone conversion. There's only one
correct way to convert a video of a
robot doing a task into the robot
controls necessary to execute that task.
And so it becomes a relatively simple
translation problem. So this is kind of
the core approach that uh you know we we
developed at ROA. And then the question
is why why isn't why doesn't everyone do
this? Why isn't it, you know, already
well established technology? And
interestingly, actually, maybe before
before I go into that, I'll just
illustrate this quick video if it if it
loads.
Okay, it's it's not going to load, but
uh you know, using your imagination,
generate the video, convert that video
to action, do this multiple times per
second, and that's how the that's how
the policy works. So, essentially, you
know, why why aren't all robots running
on on these kinds of policies? And the
answer is there's two very complex
technical challenges you need to solve
in order to control a robot with a video
model. Uh the first one is that most
video models, even though they look kind
of, you know, physically accurate,
they're not really physically accurate
once you get down into the details. And
the second is that for video models, you
need to run a video model on a robot,
you need real-time inference. And most
video models actually run quite slowly.
It takes maybe 30 seconds or a minute to
generate a video. And so just to
illustrate this, uh this is an
off-the-shelf video model. So, not not
Roda's video model, but just one that
you can kind of use online. And I
prompted it by saying, uh, I want you to
use a robot arm to pick up a Coke can.
And first of all, you know, this
actually looks pretty good. It looks
like a good, you know, visualization of
what a robot picking up a Coke can might
look like. But if you look closer, um,
look at how that thumb just goes
straight through the Coke can. Uh,
that's something that would obviously
break in the real world. It would break
the hand or it would break the can. You
know, it would be a critical failure.
And then secondly, this very short video
took 36 seconds to generate. So this is
a, you know, your state-of-the-art
off-the-shelf video model completely
unusable for robotics because a it's not
physically accurate and b it's it's, you
know, not running fast enough. And so
what we needed is a video model that
could run in maybe 200 milliseconds so
that we could do the whole task, you
know, five times a second and run in
close loop and execute the actions on
the robot. And we also wanted to build a
model that was physically accurate. And
so this required developing fundamental
technologies and actually pre-training
the video model ourselves which is you
know a very uh compute and research
intensive endeavor. Uh but we've now
actually done this work and there's a
lot of technologies we developed in the
process. One example is the way video
models uh work is they actually generate
all their frames at the same time. So if
you're generating a video that's 2
seconds all those two seconds every
every video frame is generated at the
same time. Like it goes from noise to
frame for all those frames concurrently.
Uh, obviously this doesn't work well for
real physics because you're generating
the frame where the bottle is lifting up
and where you're grasping it at the same
time, which means if you grasp it wrong,
the frame where you're picking it up is
totally independent of that. So it's
it's not represent that's not how the
world works. And so instead, we actually
pre-trained the video AR model
architecture to be causal, which means
every next frame depends on the output
of the previous frame, which is how
language models work. So that's just one
example, but there's, you know, on the
order of half a dozen technologies we
had to invent in the pre-training of
this model. But now we actually have a
model that runs in real time and is
physically accurate. And then you know
the big question is well if you have
this can you actually demonstrate
something uh using it with a robot. And
uh I'll maybe skip a couple slides here
but the the the quick takeaway is that
we're actually able to demonstrate this.
Uh so this is this is a use case uh in a
automotive factory. Uh and here what
what the robot is doing is it's actually
unpacking these boxes and and these
boxes are boxes with bearings. Um the
automotive manufacturer has to unpack
thousands of these boxes every day. And
it's something that you know requires
multiple shifts of labor and for every
part there's you know thousands of
boxes. So think of this as a task that's
an example of something that probably
thousands of people are doing at a large
factory. Uh and it's a very difficult
task because you have this very densely
packed box. You have this clear
see-through plastic. You have this
corrugated wax paper. So there's all the
things that roboticists traditionally
hate and that make, you know, a task
very difficult to automate. Deformable
materials, clear materials. Every time
the box is presented, it's presented a
little differently. The strap is in a
different configuration. Some of the
boxes are broken. And interestingly, uh,
with this approach, we're able to get
this task to work. Uh, but even more
importantly, we're able to get this task
to work with 10 hours of training data.
So in addition to the video
pre-training, we just collected about 10
more hours of robot training data and
got to a point where we were doing this
task with 100% autonomy. Um so really
you know exciting uh breakthrough here
because what what we initially you know
wanted to test when we saw this use case
was could we get this to work with a VA
uh and we we we used one of the leading
open source vals won't fingerpoint but
um essentially we gave it 20 hours of
post- training data uh and tried to run
this task in our lab uh and and what you
see in this video is the outcome it just
it just really fails to get
understanding of the task and and just
throws the whole box away uh which you
know the manual factor wouldn't have
been happy with. Uh so essentially you
know this this this paradigm has you
know real potential to automate these
tasks and do so in a very efficient way
and the key insight here is that this
works because you're not leveraging VA a
VA might leverage 100,000 hours of robot
data that's been collected in the
pre-training and that's a lot of data
but it's it's it's virtually nothing
compared to you know 10 million hours
that you need for pre-training a model.
uh and and we've pre-trained our model
with you know millions of hours of video
data and this gives it a strong enough
action prior to where it can actually do
these you know very complicated tasks
that have a lot of variability and and
you know a positive by factor of that
was that we saw that very little
teoperation data is required to teach it
the additional task. So this is kind of
a summary uh what we're doing now is
we're really focusing on uh deployments
and we we target use cases that we
believe are beyond the reach of current
automation. So tasks that currently
aren't addressed by other approaches um
and that are deployable in 2026, you
know, from our perspective and have high
scale potential. So there's some
examples here um these these are videos,
but this is really, you know, kind of
example of proof of concept deployment.
Uh and yeah, I I probably didn't mention
this, but we did a 30 box eval with this
uh proof of concept at a at a German
automotive manufacturer. And uh the
cycle time target was about 2 minutes.
We were able to beat that. Um and the
autonomy rate they wanted this to run
75% autonomously because that's kind of
what they've seen in the industry and uh
we were able to run it 100% autonomously
uh which which actually you know changes
the paradigm from needing a lot of
teleoperators to support robots to just
running the robots directly and then
importantly uh the robot data collection
is is quite uh low. Uh this third part,
if you're going to deploy a robot to do
the same task across, you know, a
thousand deployments, you might not care
very much about how much how many hours
of data it takes to train a new task.
But if you start to build, you know, if
you want to if you want to get to on a
path to generality, on a path to where
the robot can learn a new task on the
spot or, you know, do do kind of a large
number of tasks within an environment
like a household or a factory, you
really need to drive down the number of
how many additional hours it takes to
learn every additional task. And so this
robot data number while at this point
it's just a convenient you know feature
of the model over time I think this is
going to be the biggest change maker
because it it allows this modal this
type of model to be on a pathway to
generalization because if you're
operating on a household and you need to
learn every new type of dishwasher every
new type of fridge and it takes hundreds
of hours that that's just never going to
work. But if you can learn that in you
know minutes then you start to get to a
point to where you can have generalist
robots. And so um what we're doing now
is we're starting to kind of develop the
next use cases. These these two use
cases you see kind of in a in a lab view
here are ones we're deploying into
customer sites this year kind of on real
revenue contracts and not proof of
concepts. On the left is the box
decanting and on the right this kind of
material processing task uh for a
factory. Uh and then we're also doing
you know many more proof of concepts
with with with customers all around the
world. uh and we're always trying to
find tasks that are just a little bit
too difficult for other approaches. So
often we see things like clear, you
know, complex shapes uh put into pretty
tight frames or here, you know, the same
kind of plastic packaging issue uh which
is which has plagued robotics. Um, but
essentially we want to find these tasks
that are resistant to automation, have
high volume, and where there's a real,
you know, enduser customer that's going
to benefit from this technology as
opposed to, you know, just trying to
demonstrate an innovation.
Uh and then finally, one one last thing
I'll say is that uh at ROA, we think
that these first deployments are going
to require us to do the full stack work.
Everything from hardware to integration
to the foundation model because we want
[snorts] to build those, you know, early
reference deployments that prove out
that this technology can work. Uh but
there's there's two there's two, you
know, projects that we're developing uh
kind of on the tail of these first
deployments. The first is that we're
building our own hardware. Uh we spent a
lot of time you know in the market
evaluating various hardware solutions
and we found that you know we want to be
able to deliver that double OSHA payload
high reliability and you know critically
be safety rated in our in our key
markets and currently there there's not
really hardware out there that we can
buy that solves these needs and because
of that we're doing you know a large
hardware development effort but in
parallel we think that in the fullness
of time there's going to be a robust
ecosystem of both hardware and
integrators in in robotics and we think
that our real core value ad is going to
be this, you know, physical AI
foundation model. And so we're looking
to partner with both, you know, hardware
manufacturers, whether it be humanoids
or robot arms, as well as integrators
that are deploying to real customers and
let them leverage our road AI foundation
model. Uh so essentially we're building
a platform where any robot that can be
teleoperated can also be operated by our
model uh using using our APIs. Uh so in
summary uh the world action model
architecture it was it was kind of a
novel idea uh when we started but we
think this is going to be the paradigm
that actually delivers robots into the
real world uh in-house stack developed
you know we're doing deployments in 2026
and we think this will be you know the
validation the industry needs to uh you
know kind of fully pivot from the VAS to
the world action models. Uh, our model
enables resistance automation tasks
exceeding state-of-the-art performance
and it's also a very efficient learner
with only 10 to 20 hours of data. We can
demonstrate autonomy on pretty
complicated tasks. Uh, and then finally,
we're launching a platform uh program to
enable partners to leverage our
capabilities. Uh so we really think that
we want to have a lot of impact with
this model and the best way to do that
is to partner with uh you know people
that build hardware, people that work
with customers, people that want to
build the solutions and so we'd love to
empower empower you with uh with our uh
foundation model. That's all. Thank you.